il faut en parler nous sommes en direct
avec gérard longuet sénateur les
républicains de la meuse et ancien
ministre de la défense gérard longuet
bonjour merci d'être direct avec nous
alors peut-être un souvenir quelle image
vous garderez à de claude goasguen
j'en ai évidemment un album complet les
premières images chez nos premières
rencontres et il m'avait précédé henri
capt et je les ai suivis ensuite à la
fac de droit
on est étudiant ensemble je le revois
avec ses amis beaucoup de corses
d'ailleurs il est d'ailleurs lui même
d'origine corse et bretonnes et ses
démembrements et puis ensuite je les
retrouve parfois je les retrouve et on
sait jamais quitté et dans la vie
publique
il avait choisi la voix centristes tout
en restant à droite et moi j'étais à
droite tout en mettant au parti
républicain
nous avions soutenu giscard ensemble et
il était maire du xvième arrondissement
et à ce titre il a marié plusieurs de
mes filles
ce sont des souvenirs personnels qu'on
ne peut pas oublier alors c'est vrai il
était il un seul homme de conviction moi
j'aimais beaucoup cela parce que avec
lui on se savait que décision était
prise non pas en raison d'intérêts
personnels ou d'opportunités de carrière
mais parce que c'était sa conviction il
l'a prouvé encore récemment
non la lutte pour le mariage
traditionnel d'un homme et d'une femme
pour donner aux gens ce sont des parents
il s'était engagé très fortement alors
quel héritage claude goasguen leslie
derrière lui pour les militants de la
droite le la certitude que l'on peut
défendre ses convictions et exercer des
responsabilités
le compromis et la dissimulation leskiw
n'est pas un bon comportement
claude apporte la démonstration qu avec
l'idée qu'ils étaient fortes qui étaient
parfois simples cela n'arrive ils
étaient compris est suivi par ses
électeurs s'étaient pas par exemple dans
les relations internationales
analog c'était pour cette très favorable
à israël mais en même temps très ouvert
sur les bonnes relations sur la
construction européenne et sur les
bonnes relations de la russie alors un
homme qui disait les choses là est ce qu
une action collective croissance au
moment de bonheur c'était de travailler
avec mon ami alain madelin parce que ils
avaient les mêmes convictions libérales
et très complémentaires claude avait la
formule facile la formule polie ni trace
il
alain est un homme plus d' analyse de
fond et les 200 tentes et très bien mais
il était apprécié dans le groupe parce
que tout le monde le savait collectif
défendant évidemment ses intérêts mais
mais pas personnel du tout c'est la
raison pour laquelle il a été longtemps
président du groupe des élus parisiens
de la droite parisienne que justement il
fait moche erwin tous gerra longuet
merci d'avoir été en direct avec nous
sur arte france rappelle que vous êtes
un sénateur les républicains de la meuse
et ancien ministre de la défense vous
venez de partager avec nous les
souvenirs et que vous avez de claude
goasguen député les républicains on
rappelle décédé à 75 ans mercy